why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so after months of speculating after
months of postponements and so on we're
finally getting around to doing the
infinity gaunlet storyline and I am so
incredibly excited to bring this story
line to you guys because I would
consider this to be one of the absolute
greatest stories to have ever been told
in the history of Marvel Comics and most
comic book readers in terms of Marvel or
even some people who read both DC and
Marvel would rate this as quite possibly
one of the top five storylines that
anybody needs to read who's interested
in getting into Marvel and there's a
couple reasons for this right now it
looks as though almost everything that's
taking place in Marvel Comics in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is moving
towards this event is moving towards
this uh this massive space fairing uh
Venture involving Thanos and a multitude
of superheroes but the other side of
this coin is that a lot of the people
that we'll see in here we may not see
just because of the fact that Marvel
doesn't own the rights to these
characters namely the Silver Surfer who
is a major character in the story but
what we're also going to see with this
Infinity Gauntlet event is that we're
going to follow two stories the first is
going to be a story involving Silver
Surfer a story involving his arrival up
to the point when he uh meets doctor
strange and the other one is going to
involve the stories of uh Jake and Ralph
and Bambi long and we'll get into them
later on when we discuss what it is
their characters have to do with this
Infinity Gauntlet event but what we see
as The Story begins to open up is that
doctor strange is within his Arcanum
that he's simply just uh going about his
normal day and it seems here that he's
reading some kind of medical journal
that he's simply going over whatever it
is that uh he needs to read here and
this seems to be part for the course
when it comes to doctor strange and this
is just designed to introduce us to a
normal day to a peaceful day where
there's really nothing happening but
what we see is that there's some kind of
Smash some of kind of crash or loud
explosion in another room and Doctor
Strange immediately thinks that
somebody's breaking into his home that
somebody's trying to uh steal his
artifacts but when he arrives in the
Next Room what he sees is that the
Silver Surfer is uh appears to be
unconscious in his living room the
Silver Surfer is exhausted and for the
most part muttering to himself saying
things like he needs to reach doctor
strange that he must reach strange and
what we see is that doctor strange and
Wong helped silver surer to the sofa and
Doctor Strange tells him that he has
reached him that he has reach doctor
strange and Silver Surfer says that he
came to warn him came to give him a uh a
warning of a grave threat and that the
arrival could end could could Herald the
end of the universe and that this person
is Thanos that Thanos is coming from
here we switched to Silver Surfer giving
us a uh backstory on what it was that uh
that happened here and and all silver
server is really doing here is
explaining to us the events that led up
to the Thanos Quest and the events that
took place between the Thanos Quest and
The Infinity Gauntlet storyline and what
Silver Surfer tells us here is that of
course Thanos had been tasked with
eliminating half the life in the
universe by mistress death which was the
reason why he had gone on the quest of
gaining the infinity gems in the first
place so that he could achieve this task
he could perform this task without it
taking several lifetimes he could
perform the task quite quickly and uh do
it in such a way that it would satisfy
the desire of mistress death and what we
see um uh uh Silver Surfer telling us
here is that this is something this
Infinity Gauntlet that Thanos is in
possession of is something that could
destroy all of reality it could end the
entire universe and so something has to
be done here that because Thanos has
been ordered to end half the life in the
universe that forces need to be gathered
that the superheroes need to do
something otherwise everything could
come to an end from here we switch to
the perspective of Thanos and Mesto on
some unknown planet and we have
previously talked about Mesto we've
mentioned Mesto and again we're not
going to go too in-depth into his
character here but Mesto is a cosmic
entity for the most part an abstract of
of KS he's not necessarily as powerful
as Franklin Richards for example but he
is a very powerful character in his own
right but given the fact that Thanos
currently has The Infinity Gauntlet uh
Mesto really has no power that even
begins to compare to anything Thanos is
capable of and Mesto while he initially
appears to be here as an ally while he
initially appears to be here as someone
who can provide small bubbles of wisdom
for Thanos as he's uh learning how to
use this uh use this kind of power
wisely and effectively what we'll see is
that misto actually has his own agenda
here he actually has his own plans and
his own mechan naations which will come
to fruition later on and what we see is
that Thanos is uh really talking to
himself more so than he's talking to
Mesto but he says that when he initially
went on the quest when he initially
started this journey of gathering the
infinity gems that once the infinity
gems were gathered he felt as though
he'd have a million questions that he
would spend more time pondering how to
use this power than actually using it
and he says that now he only really has
one question he says the question is how
does he use such power what does he do
with such incredible power and he
answers his own question by saying that
quite simply he can do anything he wants
to because he is absolutely omnipotent
uh he says that uh for the most part if
anything happens that displeases him if
an event takes place that he doesn't
like he can simply undo it that he's
completely incapable of error that
anything he wants is his will and
because of his will anything can happen
he really presents himself here as a God
within the universe and what I would
like you guys to take a very particular
note of here is that Thanos is uh
demonstrating incredible arrogance
Thanos has come across the Infinity
Gauntlet and believes himself to be
absolute believes his power to be
absolutely incredible and that no one
can oppose him within the universe and
this will become very important
especially when we get towards the end
of The Infinity Gauntlet story line but
what we see is a Silver Surfer
commenting on this Silver Surfer is
saying that that Thanos was too arrogant
to be anyone's servant to be anyone's th
and so what we see is that uh Mesto and
Thanos transition back to to um the
layer of mistress death and we see that
Thanos as he approaches mistress death
um begins
to demonstrate to her begins to tell her
that he cares for her that uh that he
loves her that the end that in the end
all this was done for her for her love
for her affection and that what he wants
to see here is that she Express that
affection towards him that she do
something she say something to indic his
presence but all we see from mistress
death at this point is that she spurns
Thanos is that she turns Thanos away
that she doesn't return the affection
that Thanos demonstrates towards her now
from here we switch to the story of Jake
Miller Ralph and uh Bambi long and what
we see here is that these individuals
appear to simply just be in the city
there's really no um I guess context
given to them they're at a bar and
they're simply just kind of roaming
around or maybe heading back home and
perhaps they were involved in some kind
of uh bank robber or they're criminals
of some kind or something like that but
what we see is that as these individuals
are tra traveling to their next location
whatever that next location happens to
be um that they end up driving off a
cliff they end up uh driving to their
death as explained to us by whoever this
narrator is that they don't survive the
fall and from here we switch back to the
story of the Silver Surfer and what the
Silver Surfer is telling us here is that
during the time in which Thanos had
gained the infinity gems and between the
current moment when he is with Doctor
Strange that he and Drax the Destroyer
had attempted to uh to stop Thanos they
did the best they could to thwart Thanos
but Thanos had um demonstrated his power
to them and they were completely
helpless against him there was
absolutely nothing they could do to stop
him as he was warping all facets of
reality time space the mind and so on
and so what we see is that Thanos strips
their spiritual Essence from their
bodies and casts them into the soul gy
into the spiritual World from here we
see that Silver Surfer says he
encountered someone named Adam Warlock
and that Adam Warlock appeared to be the
leader of the spiritual realm now this
is the first time that Silver Surfers
ever actually come across Adam Warlock
and this is the reason why as we know
who Adam Warlock is the Silver Surfer
doesn't and so for him he doesn't know
what kind of power that Adam Warlock
possesses Hees know the role that Adam
Warlock possess or plays within the
Marvel Universe and so what Silver
Surfer tells us here is that Adam
Warlock cast a spell or uses his
abilities to eject The Souls of um of
the Silver Surfer and Drax Destroyer
back into the physical world where they
have returned to their normal bodies and
what Silver Surfer tells us again is
that he immediately uh went on a quest
to travel to the planet Earth and to uh
speak with Doctor Strange and that the
reason why this was so important was
because one the power and the role that
Thanos has been assigned by mistress
death using The Infinity Gauntlet and
two because of the fact that Silver
Surfer doesn't know how much time has
passed here he doesn't know if he was
trapped within the soul gym for days or
weeks or minutes or seconds and so his
immediate goal here is to attract the
attention of Doctor Strange at this
point we switch back to uh the story of
Jake Miller to uh Ralph and to Bambi
long and what we see is that this
narrator is telling us that the big guy
it seems to be the guy in charge had uh
waited until things cooled down before
they all went in and what we see is that
three Bright Lights travel into the uh
into the spiritual world or into the
physical world and take over the bodies
of Jake Miller Bambi long and Ralph and
we see that Ralph is a little upset by
this Ralph reacts to this saying that
this body is totally destroyed these
bodies are dead and that they can't
simply just travel around looking like
this that they have to find some way to
at the very least be discreet and what
we see is that the person who is in
possession of Jake Miller's body says
that his powers are for healing and
modifying these bodies so that they can
suit their needs and so what we see is
Jake Miller saying that um because of
the fact that he is the least injured
that he will go into the motel that
they've come across and secure their
lodging from here we see that uh Bambi
long skin appears to be turning green
which of course seems to be something
that she's happy with something that she
very much much enjoys at this point we
travel back to the story of uh Mesto and
Thanos within the realm of mistress
death and again all we really see going
on here is that mistress death is simply
continuing to scorn Thanos that she does
not return the affections that Thanos
has demonstrated towards her and she's
constantly quiet towards him she refuses
to speak to him she refuses to look at
him that even if she does look at him
she looks at him with a glance with a uh
a scornful glance and simply just turns
away and what we see Thanos doing is
trying to reason with her Thanos is
telling her that previously before he
gained the power of The Infinity
Gauntlet that he was simply a servant
towards her but now he is her equal that
she deserves better than a servant she
deserves some kind of a mate and so
Thanos views himself as somebody that
could stand in the role of being a uh
being an equal but then we see his mind
and we see his arrogance begin to
demonstrate itself and he says that he
should just be an equal to mistress
death that he should be superior to
mistress death but what we see is that
one of the Servants of mistress death
says that Thanos is in possession of
power that is so much higher than what
she has that she is no longer anything
in terms of a mate that if she had a
romantic if she returned a romantic
interest in him she would be more of a
love slave than anything else because he
could force her to do anything and so
what we see is that Thanos replies to
this by saying that she is the keeper of
his heart that he loves her with
everything that he has but this
individual says this servant says
because of the power that he possesses
that his love is stifling that his love
is bondage Thanos says no he says that
his love is worship that there should be
shrines built to mistress death that
there should be shrines built to her
greatness and so what we see is that
Thanos in the vastness of space or in
the depth of space physically creates a
shrine and transports all of them to it
which is simply just Thanos using the
reality gem for uh for his own end and
this is for the most part where we will
see Thanos remain for the remainder of
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline we won't
really see Thanos transition anywhere or
go anywhere else except for this place
and this is very important because what
we'll see is a massive event taking
place where we will see a multitude of
superheroes and Cosmic entities descend
on this place and an effort to stop
Thanos and what we see here is that
Thanos tells mistress death he has
created this place for her that this
place is a is is is designed for his
Adoration of her it is a shrine to be
built to the beauty of what he Peres to
be the idea of death we see that he
creates two chairs to sit side by side
with one another and that he and
mistress death will sit together for all
eternity and they will shape the future
of the universe they will make the
universe as they see fit they will
decide who lives and who dies they will
decide what's created and what's
destroyed but what we see is that
mistress death Contin continues to spurn
Thanos that she continues to reject any
advancements that he makes that she
continues to reject any affection that
he demonstrates for her from here we see
that um Thanos uses his abilities with
the uh Infinity Gauntlet to do what he
considers to be yet another instance of
impressing mistress death and what he
does here is he brings back nebula now
nebula had previously uh presented
herself uh to Thanos as the as his
granddaughter as the granddaughter of
Thanos and Thanos had taken her on as
his charge but eventually the time came
when Thanos realized that she was lying
that she was not his granddaughter that
she was simply just a space pirate and
so what we see Thanos doing is warping
her body transforming her body and
turning her into a corpse more or less
she's neither truly alive nor truly dead
she's just a corpse and she can never
really experience anything other than
absolute pain and the inability to stop
that pain as well as the ability to
Simply die and Thanos does this as a
creation for mistress death he does this
to um I guess as a comment of sorts on
the perversion of life and the beauty of
death but what we see is that mistress
death appears to be appalled by this she
appears to be absolutely disgusted by
this and so she again turns her back on
Thanos from here we see Thanos getting
angry with mistress death Thanos uh
screams at her he yells at her not to
turn her back on him that she needs to
face him and what we see is this servant
begins to speak again with Thanos and
says that uh that these empty boasts
that he's making that these disdainful
actions that he's committing are not
impressing mistress death they are not
not pleasing mistress death and so we
see Thanos destroys this servant from
here Thanos uh completely shows a I
guess not necessarily a 180 in terms of
his affection of mistress death but his
anger with mistress death and saying
that she will either speak to him
directly or not at all and what we see
is that Thanos continues to be angry but
we also see Mesto playing on this role
of Thanos we see Mesto playing on this
uh this this anger that Thanos has for
mistress death and what he says is that
perhaps it's something that Thanos
hasn't done the role that Thanos hasn't
fulfilled and this is when Thanos
realized that he has not done what
mistress death asked him to do the
Thanos has not eliminated half the life
in the universe and so what we see see
going on here is one of the single most
memorable moments in the history of
comic books when we see Thanos apologize
to mistress death we see Thanos saying
that he's sorry that he uh realizes
she's angry with him because his
behavior has been inexcusable that
rather than doing performing the task
that she had assigned him that he had
refused to do it or simply ignored it
and then didn't understand why it was
that she was angry in the first place
and so what we see is that misto is
shocked to see that this will actually
happen and Thanos walks to the edge of
the shrine and snaps his fingers and
when Thanos snaps his fingers it results
in half the life in the universe being
totally eradicated from here we switch
to Spider-Man and Spider-Man is
traveling through New York City he's
simply swinging from one building to
another and it's his normal night in
terms of uh looking around to see if
there's any kind of crime uh going on
and for the most part he says that he
was uh that he's calling it a night that
he's bringing this to an end and that
he's heading home but then a sudden wave
of vertigo hits him and it seems as
though his Spider Sense is going totally
arai from there there's a reaction to
everybody people are freaking out
because people are simply just Vanishing
that people are simply just disappearing
off the face of the planet but nobody
knows why and what we see here is that
Spider-Man begins to freak out
Spider-Man understands what it is that's
taking place and people are simply
Vanishing that people are simply
disappearing that no one knows where
they're disappearing to and his fear
here is that Mary Jane be one of these
individuals who have vanished and so
what we see is Spider-Man flying off or
swinging off to get back to his
apartment so that he can find out
whether or not Mary Jane is safe from
here we transition to Captain America
and Captain America is within the
Avengers headquarters and of course he's
going about his normal routine again of
just uh verifying that the premises is
safe making sure that everything's okay
and uh for the most part he doesn't
really seem it doesn't really seem as
though anything too major is happening
we see that Hawkeye along with sir are
handing Captain America some documents
talking about various things that are
taking place in the world at the moment
but then we see that midc conversation
that Cersei and Hawkeye vanish they just
totally disappear and Captain America
couldn't could absolutely do nothing to
stop this he was terrified he was
horrified because for him he knew that
some that whatever force was at work
here that whatever it happened that had
done this that had forced these
superheroes to disappear was far beyond
anything that he was capable of stopping
and so he knew that this was going to
turn into something big this was going
to turn into something massive something
that could possibly be a threat to the
universe as a whole from here we switch
to Nick Fury and Nick Fury is within the
shield Helicarrier and what we see Nick
Fury doing is simply uh going over
documentation going over the information
that's been given to him about how half
the earth population is simply just
vanished that there's nothing as far as
their investigations and shield goes
that indicates What could possibly
happen here there are no mutants that
have any sort of power that could uh do
this as far as they understand or even
if they do have that kind of power now
they haven't exercised it there's really
nothing going on here in terms of any
energy projections they've demonstrated
coming from the planet Earth that would
explain why it is that half of the life
on the planet has simply just vanished
from here we see this comic beginning to
come to a close and what we see is that
we touch back with Ralph Bambi long and
uh and Jake Miller and what we see is
that Ralph and Mandy long or Bambi long
are simply just within the hotel room
that uh Ralph is commenting that he
likes being back in the physical world
that he likes returning here and Bambi
is simply just getting used to her
having her physical body but what we see
is that uh Bambi disappears as uh as
Ralph is looking at her that she simply
just vanishes and Ralph begins to panic
Ralph doesn't know what to do here and
so what we see is that Ralph runs to the
next room and he tries to tell Jake
Miller that Bambi has simply vanished
that he doesn't know where she went to
but what we see is that in place of Jake
Miller is a cocoon indicating to us that
Adam Warlock is returning to the
physical Universe with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
later
I
you I want
open